para hacer el 70 durante el partido no
escuché nada yo no estaba enfocado en el
partido y queriendo ganar porque el
equipo que ganaba ese partido de la
tarde llévala a la zona
de oro entonces mi compañero igual que
los entrenadores pues estaba enfocado en
ese partido
y no fue hasta eso fue el domingo no fue
hasta el martes que leí
un artículo sobre sobre lo que pasó que
me di cuenta
donde yo estaba
y pues aunque no me haya afectado así
personalmente
es algo triste
todavía el garage ismo que hoy día la
gente
no pueda pasar un día sin que alguien le
diga algo sobre el color de la piel como
se ve es triste y sobre todo a mí lo que
me entristeció fue que fue en un evento
nacional donde la gente viene desde
decisiones que es que son lugares bien
negros en el país que se reúnen en un
evento nacional
pasen cosas así
gracias a dios a mí no me afectó mucho
pero alguien más pudiese haber el
afectado de manera crítica
[Música]
y son cosas que no deberían de pasar no
tiene su lugar de suerte y en el deporte
ni también
la vida de todos los días o sea la gente
tiene que tenerse derecho de poder vivir
sin que nadie lo busque y sin que nadie
lo maltrate porque es diferente a los
demás
podemos aportar un granito de
mmm
tenemos algo que aportar si tenemos algo
que aportar y esa diferencia pues así
que
cada uno de nosotros nos podemos mejorar
cada quien puede aprender de de
cualquier persona entonces
fue algo triste
son cosas que no deberían de pasar
lo malo es que ahora lo bueno es que
están haciendo una investigación y que
va haber una intervención lo malo es que
tuvo que haber eso y eso es lo es decir
porque te tuvieron que llegar
a tener que investigar ver por qué se
dijo eso quién lo dijo en qué contexto y
bueno tener que ahora poner multas van a
tener que poner multas cuando en
realidad no era necesario tal vez
necesite
si no lo hubieran dicho están borrachos
quizás quizás
paso
ojalá no vuelva a pasar pero es difícil
decir eso sea como está la cosa ahora es
bien difícil pero siempre hay que
guardar esa
actitud positiva que bueno no todo el
mundo es así quizás ellos tampoco no son
así quizás pues con los tragos se les
pasó la mano y quizás se sienten mal
quizá no se siente mal pero eso es algo
que uno no controla
eso lo podemos controlar lo que la
acción de uno mismo
cosas así pueden pasar y aquí nada más
a la página
usted cree que hay muchos
latinoamericanos en el béisbol de canadá
si soy yo he visto varios nombres si el
equipo me ahorita la mitad del equipo
son latinos
venezolanos chilenos
dominicano también entonces
los latinos estamos